[Music]  every pet knows it's a dangerous world  you'd be crazy not to worry  Thanks you're never gonna believe it  we're going on a trip maybe a break from  the city is just what you need  this places I couldn't see them because  of the town then get rid of the comb  bite therapist I need it it's a radical  device he's doctor there you're cured  hallelujah  [Music]  Oh  [Music]  yeah I'm gonna be the first buddy  washboard abs  I need you for top secret  - don't be so dramatic  [Music]  but yes probably the first step of not  being afraid like you're not free where  are you going  so are you scared no are you scared  no no I'm not now you're talking  you want to join me  [Music]